let's check the time okay hi my name is
jim
i gave a talk three years ago at pi data
meetup in london and it was it was
actually the first recorded talk on an
open source feature store and today will
be the first of a new next generation of
feature store i'll get to it at the end
um that's the promise so this talk is is
is about feature stores but it's within
the context of a problem so a year ago i
moved apartment and i found this cd up
in the corner and it was a project that
i worked on in 2004 with kieran lee who
subsequently co-founded intercom i think
he's 63 on ireland's rich list
um but um the problem was basically i
used to love surfing and he did too and
we wanted to go down to the west coast
of ireland at the weekend and would
there be surf would there not be surf so
what we did was we built a system of
course it was machine learning and we
even published on it in icml
and it was basically taking open ocean
swell predictions so the americans have
these boys or buoys out in the atlantic
and somebody on the west coast of
ireland
in a shop in lahinch he basically
measures the height of the waves every
day and he publishes them
so it's a very simple curb fitting
problem
and just a little bit of background so
you learn a little bit about surfing it
was one of my passions
um waves as you know have a direction
they have a period or a wavelength
and they also have a height so you can
see on this on this image on the right
we can see that the swell is coming in
from the north and you can see it hits
this point and at that point you can see
the lines compress so the wave actually
go increases in height the period stays
the same but the wavelength decreases
and you can see the beach that the waves
are much smaller than they are at the
point so the problem of predicting the
high height of a wave at a beach has a
lot of parameters around it but these
are the main ones that you need to know
for the predictions out in the atlantic
so in the atlantic it looks like this if
you look on the bottom left there's an
image and you can see there's a boy out
there
and that's a boy run by noah and
we can see that it's producing this
tabular data you can get on the internet
and it has actually information on the
height of the swell the period and the
direction and you can see there's
actually multiple swells here because in
the atlantic you can have different
storms sending in swells so you need to
pick the rights well because we'll see
that you know some of the spells may go
into the beach and some don't
so a bit of feature engineering will be
needed um
somebody on the beach gives us these
reports which we can scrape from the
website which is great
and we do need to do a little bit more
feature engineering because you know we
get these uh predictions out in the
atlantic but at a certain time but it
takes a certain amount of time for that
swell to reach the beach in ireland so
we need to do some feature engineering
there
it's not too hard because you can
calculate the swell velocity by
multiplying the swell period by 1.5 and
you also know the direction of the
swells you know roughly when this well
is going to hit land
a lot of surfing you didn't think you'd
come here for surfing and we also need
to know the angle of the swell coming in
so when we have multiple swells we're
going to pick the best well based on the
whether it fits inside the swell window
at this particular beach in ireland
now here's what we built this is where
it's kind of where we're into the meat
of the talk so we built a system
um it was about 8 000 lines of code
primarily java php a lot of sql
and it was a k-nearest neighbors model
there's actually a few of them and we
kind of average over them
and the question i had when i saw the cd
at the
last year i said well geez i wonder if i
reimplemented this thing right
what would it look like and
the reason why our website is no longer
online if you go to cj surf we had that
on the website was it cost i think like
a hundred dollars a year to to host it
and we just did with no cash
like he may have been one of ireland's
richest people now but we know cash at
the time so we just let it fall
so what if you could write this system
on free managed services including a
feature store in 2022 so that's what i'm
going to talk about here can we can we
redo this thing in python and can we run
it for free without having to pay
anything and the answer is yes of course
but we'll see it in a second
so the the system that we started out
with at that time in 2004 it was a lamp
stack right so we have a java program
scraping from these websites
um it's writing data to my sql server
it's using k n to make predictions we
train the model and it writes the
predictions to our database and then we
have php web app which looks up the
pre-computer predictions and you get to
see your surf height at the beach
so what would that lamp stack look like
if you're to rebuild it as a serverless
web application
so what you would need is you'd need on
the left you'll need some sort of
serverless orchestrator we need to run
the feature pipelines to pull the data
from the observations
the swell predictions
we'll need to
make predictions we need to have a batch
program which runs once a day
and because we get new data once a day
in fact we'll see we get data every six
hours from the boys the the data from
the beach only comes once every day
you need to train models but you can do
that offline
and then we'll need somewhere to store
this data so we're going to have this
these features related to the
surf report observations and the the
swell predictions
and we'll need to have a model we need
to store that somewhere and then we'll
need to have some sort of front end that
we can provide to users
so this is what i'm going to show uh in
the talk
um and you we basically
have to
uh
use some sort of orchestration tool
which we you can use github actions
there's a bunch of other ones out there
um i'm going to use jupyter notebook for
model training because it's on my laptop
hopsworks is the platform that we build
it's an open source platform
it's also now a serverless platform
we'll see at the end
and it has a model registry in it and it
has a feature store so it's actually
best known as a feature store because it
was the first
open source feature store out there and
what we'll do is we'll look at how we
can write the features with feature
pipelines to hopsworks we can train
models in your laptop or in co-lab
and you can then write predictions to
the feature store as well and they can
can be consumed by a streamlive app so
those you don't know streamlet it's you
can write a ui in python very easily
it's a very few lines of code
the whole thing went from 8000 lines of
code it's open source i'll give you a
link later it's less than a thousand
lines i'm not sure exactly how many
because it's notebooks and i don't know
how to do a wc minus l in a notebook yet
um
so there is another way you could do it
on our platform but i'm not going to
talk about it today just in case you're
curious you could also deploy the model
on our platform because we're also doing
serverless model hosting so deployed
models
it's k-server under the hood and your
stream application could make
predictions as they
as requests come in using precomputed
features in the feature store but we're
not going to do that today but maybe for
interested to be a really interesting
alternative
architecture
so what i thought i'd do um the reason
why i thought this was an interesting
project to begin with was
the feature store and feature
engineering you have a lot of challenges
and we solved a lot of these challenges
when we built cj surf
and one of them that you have is point
in time joins and i'll show how it's
easier in the feature store
so we had two tables we had the surf
reports in the top left hand corner so
these are coming from the hinch
tom was putting these out daily and
we're scraping them and building up the
tables
and then we have these swells coming in
from the noah boys and they're updated
every six hours so you can see they have
different update cadences the one on the
left is updated daily and the on the
right is update every six hours so when
you want to create training data to
train a model you need to account for
that difference
so what you need to do is what we call a
point in time correct join we don't want
any data leakage what we want to have if
we look at the training day at the
bottom for every row we're going to take
the observation in the table in the top
left to the surf report observation and
we're going to pick out
the height direction and period
at the hits at time so the hit time was
the time we predicted this would
um this swell would arrive at the beach
and but we don't want future data in
there right so we don't want we want the
most recent hits up observation on the
right we don't want one that's too early
because then it won't be good we don't
want that's too late because then we'll
have data leakage
so this is how we did it in this is just
some code i pulled out of the source
code i found
you know it's pretty ugly
at sequel like not super easy to debug
not super easy to embed in your programs
um it's an sql bomb that's actually a
wave in ireland
um in sligo look more
and we have a summer house down there
it's lovely
so this is how you would do that so
obviously people aren't interested in
looking at sql and going through it this
is how you would write this in our
platform hopsworks you can see we have a
dsl so it's a python-based dsl
and lahinch there is what we call a
feature group it's a representation of
this table so the term feature group is
using feature storage to represent
tables or features
and we have a second feature group
called swells so what we're doing is
we're selecting the feature called wave
height from the lahinch table and we're
selecting from the swells table the
height the period and direction and we
get back at what we call a query object
and you can just inspect the data you
can get a data frame from it have a look
at it but we typically do is we create a
materialized view of that
query we call that a feature view so
it's a view over the tables that are
there because in a feature store you're
going to have many features in many
different tables and you'd like to reuse
those features across different models
you would say i'd like that feature that
feature that feature give me some
training data and this is the api for
doing it
so you know if you read the intro to the
talk it said well you know how do people
do this in feature stores right now
um the world has kind of gone into two
we have the python community here and we
have the sql community here there are
many people in the snowflake um new
new sql new data warehouse kind of space
you think that all of this should be
done in sql and it should be run
directly on your back end
um actually we agree because you're not
going to be able to do this
point in time join if you're downloading
data frames in in pandas that are you
know terabytes in size you're not going
to be able to do this
you want to have technology that enables
you to do this irrespective of the
amount of data at the back end
so you can write it purely in sql in you
know snowflake or redshift or bigquery
but we saw what you have to do we have
to write this horrible
um code so what we have here is a nice
dsl it transpiles into sql and then we
execute it on the back end in our
platform
so from your perspective as a developer
you're writing python native code and
but it will scale out
if needs to at the back end
and then this set of features that we
get together we call that a feature view
we'll go into that in a little bit
that was problem number one the second
problem that we had
um is that you we saw actually earlier
sarah had a talk where she talked about
just this problem with
um uh standard scalars and psychic learn
that you maybe your inference pipeline
is different to your training pipeline
so
if you have um
in our case we have three features
height period and distance of our swells
that we're going to use to predict the
height of the wave at the beach what if
we normalize these will it improve
the you know the accuracy of our model
and actually this is actually a
classification problem but i just showed
the rmse because it's more intuitive i
guess
um but you can see that you know
normalizing them makes a little bit of
difference
um so wouldn't it be nice to normalize
um these features
for training and also in our inference
pipeline and you can do it and you know
we did it before
and what we have to do is you have to um
you have to ensure that you're using the
same code
the same transformation functions with
the same parameters and sarah showed how
she exported the parameters to files and
um you know read them up again but you
can also just dump your
scalar object and read it up again as
long as the version of psychic learn in
inference is the same as it is in
training which is of course a potential
problem so there's a lot of you know
issues can arise in this so that we we
call this training serving skew when
there's difference between us so in our
platform
how you handle training serving sku is
you can write your own transformation
function we have obviously built-in
transformation functions like
scikit-learn's standard scalar
and what you do is you can see here on
the top left what we have is we've in
this case i'm i'm applying the standard
scalar to three features so i say okay
these three features i want to run them
through standard scalar and then all i
need to do is call trains test split and
i'll get back my training and test sets
and labels features and labels
and then in inference i don't do
anything it's like so what has happened
here is that the feature store is
storing the metadata about the
transformation so the standard scalar
parameters that we saw in sarah's talk
they're being stored in the feature
store and then they're being retrieved
transparently from here because this
feature view object that we have both in
training and an inference
it knows about the the data that you're
trained on and the parameters of the
features so the descriptive statistics
that are used to compute the
uh you know the to compute the
transformation function here at the
standard scaler
so a third problem that you have is well
what happens when i'm downloading from
tom's website
if uh if he put in 100 instead of 10
foot for the height of the wave which
might be you know an outlier we didn't
obviously do any data validation
back at the time
but what we've added to our platform is
something called great expectations many
of you may have heard of it there was a
tutorial yesterday
so what you would like to happen is that
your date is validated before it's
written to the feature store
and in this case you can if you look in
bold you can see that that i've added an
expectation saying the wave height
should be between 0 and 20 because you
don't get 120 waves at the hinge the
other places will look more that's a lot
higher
and what you do then is when you define
your feature group the table of features
you just say this is the expectation
suite that we have defined in great
expectations and every time i insert the
data frame because when we write to the
feature store we write data frames so
pandas data frames or spark data frames
and it'll validate the data before it's
written to our platform
and there is one other feature store
which does the opposite which we think
is a bit crazy where they validate data
reading from the feature store so in
general i think it's better to have
clean data in your feature store from
the beginning rather than validated when
you're reading it
so you get these nice visual reports
that we'll see in a little bit later
okay so what is a feature store i've
talked about some of the problems that
it solves i haven't defined what the
thing is
um this is this is our view of feature
stories i think this as if you're a
developer this makes it as easy as
possible for you to
to to think about the concepts you're
going to write these feature pipelines
to create features and they'll write
these things called feature groups
feature groups are the tables of
features and they're mutable you write
to them you update them
the feature views on the other hand they
read that's where you want to read from
the feature store you create a feature
view and reading can have two different
components you can read
from the feature views to create
training data or to create batch scoring
data so it's going to be a high
throughput api to get you csv or tf
record files or to get your pandas data
frame
and then you when you're in inference
you might want to read your precomputed
features you're going to say okay give
me these swell
direction and height of of the waves and
um you want that to happen at very low
latency this is where the feature stores
slightly different to a data warehouse
we have a very low latency api for
online serving and then we have a high
throughput high bandwidth api for
offline access
now internally how that's implemented
is that you have one database so it's a
dual database system all feature stores
out there now are dual database there
was one that was hybrid but it's
actually now since um
they what company went bust
um but you basically have have a low
latency database for for the online api
for retrieving the feature vectors and
then you have some scalable database for
the offline data so in our platform you
can have your offline data in any
external data warehouse so you can mount
them in
and but the online data we store in our
own database called rondb so we're
actually x mysql people and and the
michael ronstrom's it's a fork of the
database called mysql cluster
and then offline if you do write the
features offline to our platform we use
apache hoodie and the reason why we use
these technologies is that you want to
have guarantees when you're writing the
data
that
when it gets ingested that you have
consistency of the features between
online and offline so we achieved that
by writing to kafka
which gives us at least once semantics
guarantees and then through item potency
to the online feature store and then the
asset properties of hoodie writes we
ensure that the data lands at the data
is consistent between the online and
offline stores
and you have to ensure that you know
that schemas matches across them
so i defined what feature view is but
let me just walk you through the steps
of creating a feature view so we've got
our two tables of features at the top
the the surf reports from the beach and
then we've got the predictions from the
ocean so we're going to select the
features from those different tables and
then we're going to apply
transformation functions to some of
those features so a feature view if you
think of it as a type
a set of
columns it actually also has
transformation functions associated with
the data types so feature view is not
just a set of data types or columns it's
also the transformation function so it's
an extended
type if you will
and then you also want to define the
label because we're doing supervised
machine learning here
when you're creating your feature view
and then the feature view can be used as
we see in the middle for get feature
vectors for for retrieving um individual
feature vectors for serving and then
when we want to create training data
from it we can say well do i want pandas
data frames or files
and can i filter out because maybe i
don't want to have all the data i want
to filter out just the beach lahinch and
just the boy
68021
and then i want to maybe create random
splits of my data or maybe time-based
splits and you can do that all in the
api so the feature view kind of looks
like this
you know the data is being written to
these feature groups the feature view
allows you to create these immutable
snapshots
of training data
and back scoring data so when you train
your model
you'll say i'll have the data from this
starting point to this endpoint
and then you say give me the data that
arrived since then and i'll score it so
in that case that's what we're doing for
for predicting on our surf page we'll
say okay give me all the
um you know the the predictions that
have come in from noaa and i'll compute
or estimate the wave heights for the
next period of time
and then finally you know when the
observations come in you can create more
training data and retrain your models
so the models themselves um
you know that we store them in our
platform so
uh some of the things that you can do is
uh you know you create your training
data with this feature view api
and then you you're in in jupiter or in
collab um
and you want to train a model so so in
this case i use knn and i'll go through
the notebook in a minute and for
training the model and then other things
you might want to do with a feature
feature view is very useful you can say
okay i'd like to create evaluations like
met or data sets so you might say in in
this case it's there's no personal
information involved but you know if i
was working with customers and we had
let's say 10 different groups of
customers i might say well i'd like to
have from my test set i'd like to create
10 different sizes of that test set
sliced along these different groupings
of customers and then i'd score my model
against all 10 groupings to ensure that
the model doesn't have bias
so that's a really useful um property
that you can do in your with your
feature views in the feature store
and then finally when you want to if you
want to deploy a model um as an endpoint
so you're going to make calls and over
the network
um you can do that as well in the
platform
so i'm going to go through the code but
let me show you the whole architecture
it's all available on
github
so what we have here if we look at it is
on the left hand side we have
our data so we have the website that
we're going to scrape data from the
hinge surfshop website
we have csv files we've uh
so i found on my c on my c on my cd i
found some csv files unfortunately it
wasn't great data because it was missing
tons of data but i kind of put something
together
so
um
when so i have a program on on the um
there's a notebook in this uh github url
called surf report feature pipeline i
think it's the hinge report for future
pipeline and you can run either to
backfill data from the csv file um to
create your first set of features and
then you can run a um not backfilling
which means it goes to the website
downloads today's observation or surf
report and writes it to
um the feature group so these things
the the surf report
feature pipeline and also the swell
prediction feature pipeline they're
feature pipelines they're they're taking
data they're computing features as
pandas data frames and they're writing
them to these feature groups
now once you have your feature groups in
place we create one feature view that's
all we need here
which will contain the height of the
wave at the beach and then the three
parameters the features we need um to
make the prediction on the swell so the
height of the swell the period of the
swell and the direction of the swell
so with this feature view we can create
training data and there's a notebook for
that called model training pipeline and
then there's another
program called batch predictions
pipeline and that is going to run you
should run that every day right it's
going to make new predictions you'll
update
um the predictions in fact you can run
it every six hours because no update
their swell predictions every six hours
so it'd be probably better to run every
six hours
so what that program does is it just
writes to
the the output to a feature group
because the feature is just a table
and then we have a stream that
application
that shows you uh the the wave predict
predictions so i'm going to walk through
these different steps
let's look at i did promise you we would
do this serverless um
it's not about github actions i'm not
going to go through the git of actions
but you can you can run all of these
notebooks you can use nb convert to
convert them to python files and and run
them and you can schedule them using git
of actions if you want there are plenty
of other free orchestrators out there
so that's one way of doing it and then
the
the data and the models so the two
feature groups the feature view
so the output predictions that's another
feature group and then the model itself
will all be stored in hofsworks in our
platform
and then finally we have streamlift to
do the ui and it kind of looks like this
it's not this is just generated this
morning it's not particularly beautiful
um but you can see that it's predicting
the wave height somewhere between one
and three feet for the next
uh week or so
so let's have a look at some of the code
for this um
are you with me
okay so this is the platform here
you can see the url in the top corner
hopefully you can see that i can zoom in
a little bit
um
it's called hopsworks.ai and if you go
to apps.hopservers.i you can you can try
and reproduce this now
but what we can see is i'll start with
the programs we can see that there are
the feature groups here so we have
um features it's using my phone because
the wi-fi sucks here as you you all i'm
sure know
uh but let's have a quick look at the
the hinge data because these are these
are the um the features the surf reports
so there's not that many features we've
got like the beach id because maybe i
want to add this to other beaches and
that's our primary key the observation
time is the event key on this particular
so that's what we use for the point in
time joins
it's the time at which the report is
made and then we have the height of the
wave in fact there's three different
um parameters given by the surface part
they often give a max height at min
height
um so sometimes so you could extend this
example to also predict max and minhys
as a label but what we can see here like
if you have a feature store you say okay
i can see the provenance where these
features are used for training
i can see when we had some expectations
in this case we expected the wave
between 0 and 20 fees and we can see the
result of them here so if there were
errors in the pipeline you can see them
here you could also set up an alert here
to get a ping in slack
and to say hey you know there's a
problem with the expectation or problem
with the job
so it's all this kind of useful tooling
for for getting this thing uh running
one thing that i find is very useful for
um
debugging is just getting quick preview
of your data
so one thing i didn't mention i
mentioned there is an offline store in
an online store
and i didn't go into the details about
those but i'll mention it here the
offline store stores the latest value of
features only right it's typically used
for the because you're only going to use
it to retrieve the latest values of
features to make predictions so in this
case you can see there's only one
observation here which is
uh this is from today i believe yeah
no this is actually an older one
this is a preview it's not showing it's
just picking a random observation so you
can see that was the data we collected
in 2004
um and the height of the wave at that
day was
three feet
um by the way if you're curious waves
are measured in feet and they're
measured from behind so three foot wave
is actually this high
and it's called hawaii at the hawaii
measurement
so that's the uh that's the online
measurement so the offline store doesn't
store the latest values of features it
stores the historical value features
we're going to use that to create
training data and it's going to have all
the values of features over time because
they get updated over and over and over
again in time
so
you know your offline store could have
huge amount of data going back to a very
very long time
um and we can see here it's taking a few
seconds to load so this is actually you
know this data is stored on hoodie
and it takes a few seconds to load
um and you can see as well that we'll
have a look in a second that when you
write your pandas data frame to the
feature store
this seems to be hanging and i don't
have to blame my internet or
or blame the blame somebody else but
we'll we'll we'll see if it's the
internet here no so this one moved on so
let's look at the statistics um
so when you write this
table of this pandas data frame um it
computes statistics i i turned on
computing statistics you can turn it off
if you want but it's very useful for eda
so you want to basically have a quick
look at your data and we can see here
for the height of the waves that you
know there's a lot of if we look at the
size of them here you know
um there's a lot of uh
low
waves that are quite small and then
there's a few of them that are very high
and
you can see this here's our wave height
again here
so you know we also can be i computed a
correlation matrix here i don't know if
that was of any use
um but you can also see what's happened
right so you can look at the activity of
on this particular feature group over a
period of time
so we can see here that that you know i
i did the backfill here and then i ran
and downloaded from the internet and off
we went
so there's also feature views here this
is the feature view that i created and
we can see um
like for this particular feature view we
have hundreds of features actually so
you can see here that
not just the wave height and the
direction but all of the
um for every hour i think for 120 hours
i have the the swell height
um the direction and the the estimated
time it hits that so you can have you
know potentially models with hundreds of
features that's fine
um
and let's have a look at the code
because that's more interesting i guess
let's see how are we doing for time
so let's start at the our feature
pipelines
so how do we compute this so firstly you
need to install a library
um hopsworks is all you need
um in this case i i set backfill to
false but you know that means going to
go the internet download
from the website the height of the waves
and it's going to have a data frame so
we're going to have a data frame so
either when we're back filling or
download the internet we'll have this
data frame df with our
data we define our expectation suite
here
we log into the platform so
if you're just running this
interactively it'll redirect you to the
website give you an api key which you
paste in here but you can set an
environment variable as well so it'll
just go straight through
um and then to write to the feature
store you can see it's pretty
straightforward code here
we have this thing called
fs object the feature store object and
we just get a reference
to that and we call the get or create
feature group the name of the feature
group description whether it's going to
be online or not primary key the
expectation suite
am i going to compute statistics and
then the column that has the event time
and then i just insert that data and it
gives you a link to an ingestion job so
if you're using the server's platform
it'll show you these were the jobs that
ran to ingest the data and the results
of them you can get your logs there
and
so that's that's the um
that was the first pipeline which is
writing to the the observations at the
beach
the one from noaa which is our swell
heights we're doing this something
similar we're going the internet
scraping data we can backfill there's
more feature engineering in here because
we have to select the correct swell we
can have multiple competing swells so we
take the one that that's highest but
within the swell window
and um
then we
then we basically come down here we have
a data frame ready to go and we just
write it again so it's very similar to
what we saw before you can see you
notice i don't have expectations set up
here on this website because nowhere
pretty good
i didn't think it was needed
and then i want to to train a model
so i need to have my feature view so
in this case what i'm going to do is
again we'll log into the platform
i've got some transformation functions
that are defined here um i need to do it
over all the hours because we can have
in this case i may have you know
hundreds of features because i i need
four features for or three features for
every hour and i want to predict the
next 120 hours um so here i'm joining
the features together this is our
dsl that i mentioned you can see we've
got the lahinch feature group the swells
feature group i'm basically selecting
the wave height from the
observations and then i'm selecting all
of the features from the swells feature
group except the beach id and you can
see that the sequel that you would have
to write
here you go
would you like to write that like
i wouldn't like seriously but i didn't
have to worry about it here and that's
just you know i you can see that my data
was a bit dirty i didn't have in in when
we stored the data before i didn't store
the predictions for the next hour and so
on so a lot of nans in the data i just
had the observations at the actual time
so i need to collect better data
in the future so with that um query
object i can create my feature view here
and we say that the label is where
the wave height
there isn't that much data here so
typically i would just get back at
pandas four pandas data frames the
the features the labels for training and
testing
um if you want to store it on disk you
can call this you can see here we can
store the csv files you can also
coalesce them into a single file and
this is going to run a spark job in the
background so it'll create lots of small
files if you don't but if you coalesce
it and you don't have enough memory in
the driver
um it won't work so you need there's a
little bit of knowledge needed there
and but if you write them to the
platform you can also just retrieve them
which is a bit faster you can say okay
just download the uh the features and
labels for the train and test sets
so in this case actually i got back a
lot of labels so i just selected the
ones i needed for training
and then i'm using
scikit-learn
i'm also encoding the label here
and
then i'm using k-nearest neighbors to
train the model and
then and now i know i just basically
compute the the
metrics on the model i did the rms e
just for for fun but it is a
classification problem so
and this is the how it fitted right it
wasn't like super brilliant we had much
better in xeros and four but i didn't
have uh correct data so i'm going to
collect data in the next one and this
will get better but it's good enough if
you're surfing it gives you a general
idea if there'll be waves or not
so um once i've got my model trained um
you
this is where the we have the data frame
which contains information about the
features that we use to train the model
so that is actually used to create the
schema
of the the model because remember your
model has a schema an input scheme as
well in an output schema
so when we store our model in the
model registry we yes we serialize it we
don't put as a pickled python object
but what we also do which is very
interesting here is we can also store
you can see it says your input example
equals input example
so this input example is just a sample
from the input training data so if we
store that along with the model
it means then when you're trying out
your model and testing it there's an
input example ready you can just press
click and it's great it's really nice
for for debugging your models so then
you save your model to the model
registry you can deploy it for serving
and
you're good to go
so the last thing um then once you have
your model up and running let's have a
quick look at that by the way because we
didn't look at that
so the models here
you can see here i've got a model
registry there's only one called cj
surf model i played around with the
different uh versions of it everything
is versioned here by the way including
feature groups and feature views and and
that versioning is is the schema because
that's what you need to version um
above all else that when you change the
scheme and make breaking changes and
downstream clients should be aware of
that
so this particular model you can see
we have we stored the model metrics so
when i published the model model
registry i had a dict with the metrics
and that you can see them here we can
see that's being used in one deployment
and then we can see the input output
schema and you can have tags and so on
for governance
and then the model that's actually
running
you can see it here it's running
now let's let's go and look at the last
thing that we have which is the
prediction pipeline
so the prediction pipeline is the
program that's going to run
every six hours or every day to to
generate our new um user interface
so what it's going to do is it's going
to download our model which you can see
here so it's going to connect to the
model registry download it
and unpickle it and then it's going to
and this is just testing the the feature
vector but what it's basically doing is
it's going to download all of the
feature vectors for the
um
from the online
that we get when we say give you the
latest values of the features so the
latest values of the features will be um
120 hours worth of uh
input swell heights so noah tells us for
at hour number one we'll have this swell
height period and direction and error
number two it'll be this and so on so
we're going to get a different
set of features for each of those hours
so we're going to make predictions for
all of those
because basically building up a data
frame with those
and then we write the um
then we have the the prediction is
happening we say
yeah so then we we actually make our
prediction here
so we're so we're making our prediction
here and we're writing out the
prediction it's just another column in
our in our
um output data frame and we write it out
to the platform here
so then finally the streamlet app that
looks here
that looks like this it gives it the
output its code looks like the following
um
it's pretty straightforward
uh it all fits on one page we can see
here that we we give a title to the web
page in the subheader
and we connect to the feature store we
read these precomputed features from the
online feature store of that feature
group
and then we basically display them with
a line chart so it's just doing a couple
of other things related to converting
the
types of the columns
so that's basically it that's our that's
our end to end
serverless
wave prediction i would call it
prediction service right
so just a little bit like um you know
context
what we want people to be able to do
with this is build prediction services
right so if you want to demo to your you
know to your colleague or to someone
else
that hey i you know i'm training a model
and i can show the model fits the data
that's not communicating to stakeholders
the value of your model what what does
is a prediction service something that's
going to
maybe predict fraud or maybe going to
predict
um you know a recommender system you
want to show an end-to-end demo
and to do that you need to build what we
call an ml flywheel right an ml5 wheel
is what i kind of covered there that we
have to have some data coming in and we
had our data dump of the the you know
the
web heights and the predictions we store
them in the feature store we train the
model
we serve the model in this case we're
doing an analytical ml application
and then we need to have a way of
collecting new data so we need to ensure
that new data comes in so features
should get logged
outcomes should get logged
and that new data will feed in to create
better models and hopefully better
models will mean you get more data which
means you'll get better models which
means you get more users hopefully
and better services so this is what we
call the the the ml flywheel and you
need to get it going and you can do that
in serverless uh with our platform
hopsworks so i did promise you that um i
would say announce something new
and so we're announcing here now the the
first ever serverless feature store uh
and also model serving infrastructure
hopsworks and you can register here um
it's exclusive to pi date and loan by
data london we're not announcing this
yet
um and it's something you can use this
is not something that's a demo that
we're going to take off you next week
um free forever in inverted commas
um as you know you know that you know
the conditions associated with that but
you'll be able to you'll be given um and
i can show you some of the what does
that mean if we go back to the platform
here
uh we can see here if we just look at
our home
there's some quotas so you can have like
a couple of gigabytes of data you can
run five parallel ingestion jobs or
training creation jobs 30 feature groups
offline two models servings or
deployments in parallel basically you
can build these prediction flywheels and
try them out
and the
the barrier to entry which is often just
i don't pay for a docker container being
you know served on
on sagemaker and we removed that so
you'll be able to build prediction
services not just
models
and i think you can do that end
end-to-end in python i think this is an
important part of enabling people to
build end-to-end prediction services in
python
so um if you want the slides you can
maybe follow my twitter i'll post some
variant of them maybe this evening
and go to hopsworth.ai and app.hop6di if
you want to try this out talk to us we
have a booth outside
um and this is a cool and beers are on
us
we're giving out beers we're sponsoring
beers this evening
so um we're around talk to us if you're
interested if you find this
um in any way
potentially useful for you
and whether you're whether you're just
hacking or whether you're doing bigger
projects
we're interested
thank you very much
and so the question is about ingress and
egress from the warehouses is is that
a limitation potentially well when you
write to the feature store you write
data frames um either pandas or in in
spark and we i showed a slide where we
we ingest them into into kafka and then
we manage the consistency of them
between the online and offline stores so
that's something you shouldn't have to
worry about
but but i guess there is the egress from
the well the feature view we saw was the
main mechanism from egress where you
read either training data or batch
scoring data as data frames or files and
then you read individual feature vectors
when you're serving and you need
features to pre-computed features for
your models so that's the egress in this
case
okay
okay
and sorry and the other question was
just about um
if
uh if there is already some feature um
engineering happening say with dbt
uh as part of uh
well big or something then is that
something that can be kind of yes
just consume it
we can take an existing table um
from snowflake or redshift or or data
lake and and just mount it as a table a
feature offline feature group in there i
think there's one more maybe time for
one more
i'll repeat this
great calculator
hi thanks
assuming you're calculating that across
the entire the offline store every time
there's a new ingestion have you thought
about or do you have any plans for
data feature concept drift tools
detection tools yeah so the question is
related to to drift right so there's
different types of drifts you have
feature feature shift not drift because
that's as individual feature changing
and then you have um drift which is
typically concept drift when the model
doesn't make predictions that because
the underlying
um prediction problem has changed so
what we do is we we we do right now is
we capture all of the logs
and the feature logs the and there's two
different types of logs in fact for
features you have transformed values and
untransformed values so transformed are
pretty useless so you need to capture
the untransformed values and then you
have obviously the predictions so we
push them all into kafka
and right now you have to write a
program yourself to uh you know to do
that to do because every prediction
problem and it has different notions of
what is anomalous for that particular
problem so you know there are algorithms
we actually have an out of the box kind
of one which will do
um you know um
um uh kale divergence but that's pretty
standard and what what wasserstein at
distance as well
but you know
that's something that we're working on
as well
okay
thank you very much
[Applause]